we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
I'm Dave Ramsey your host this is common
sense
for your dollars and cents common sense
is so rare in America today it's like
having a superpower
if you just stop and think
it will completely set you free
it's pretty amazing
our question of the day today today's
question comes from Andre in the Ramsey
Baby Steps Community which is a Facebook
community of about I don't know half
million seven hundred thousand so big
bunch of folks over there so our house
needs a new furnace oil tank and water
heater they're all 40 years old the hot
water heater doesn't even work and the
other things work but not for much
longer we want to sell the house next
year and I'm worried we won't get the
money back I know this is maintenance of
a home but in today's market uh can I
view this as an investment and will it
help us sell the house to have all new
essential items
well if I'm you Andre I at least want to
get those things in working condition
because if I'm buying a house I would
like to know that there's a working
water heater I would like to know that
there is working heat in a furnace I'm
not saying that you have to go in and
spin top dollar you know at the top of
your budget for all of these items but
it's not going to hurt you to have a
working home before you put it on the
market that's what I would say yeah and
if you're using this as a justification
to overspend on these items or to go
deeply in debt no we're not going to go
with air right make sure you've got a
problem before you sent this email you
don't have hot water I mean come on
really this is pretty big sick stuff
here so yeah you need to fix your
freaking hot water heater or replace it
now I don't know about the furnace in
the basement I don't know whether you've
got the one from the Christmas story
movie or what it is you've got down
there but
um
but the thing I've learned is you can
patch those things together most of the
time and yeah what often happens is the
heating and air person that comes
actually wants to sell you a new unit
rather than fix it and so they're really
good at scaring you to death oh you've
got a family he's not gonna die this
thing's gonna blow up yeah you get all
this crap some not all of them obviously
there's some good heating and air people
out there we endorse good heating and
air people that are honest all over the
nation but uh but there is a bit of a
problem in that community so be careful
with that don't overspend is the point
well something tells me she doesn't have
any money yeah a house that doesn't have
heat and air and hot water is not
marketable no so you've got to fix it to
sell it and you should fix hot water to
live in it and you should have heat for
the winter I mean this is pretty basic
stuff but what's what he's not saying
here is is that I have a bid for twenty
five thousand dollars and I want to go
steeply in debt on a second mortgage and
put it under air quotes of an investment
that's what it is none of that is in
here but I read every bit of it in there
yeah that's what it is that's what it is
and I I don't think he's got cash
stacked up for this if I'm guessing this
is something that he was hoping he could
pull out I'm dead or else and he
wouldn't have asked us he wouldn't be
taking cold showers if he had cash
stacked that's my guess I think you're
right Jacobson Grand Rapids Michigan hi
Jacob how are you
yeah better than I deserved Dave how
about you better than I deserve what's
up
hey so um I just started following you
guys and me and my wife got married last
year and we uh sold our house and moved
to a less busy area that was actually
cheaper and so we came into kind of a
windfall of money through that so after
our down payment and everything and we
have our our six months Reserve we have
about 60 000 in the bank we were looking
to do something with and uh given my
situation during college I uh qualified
for the full twenty thousand dollar uh
relief package to the new Biden uh
student loan forgiveness and obviously
that's in limbo right now so my question
is I have about 36 000 left in student
loan debt should we just pay it off
right now or should we wait to see what
happens
okay
um
well the thing I have figured out is
over the years that um
well I mean we just need to preface this
jacob with I'm old okay and I have seen
a lot of promises that were going to fix
my life come from Washington DC
uh the number of them that have
materialized is approaching zero
and so my what I discovered a long time
ago is is that people that wait on the
government to fix their lives generally
have lives that suck
sure and so I you know have you noticed
that this has been dragging out for like
two and a half years now
yeah yeah and that it's now before the
Supreme Court
which is when at what happened after it
went to the Circuit Court which is what
happened after Biden went ahead and just
did it and it didn't work and uh the
timing was always uh suspect around the
midterm elections and all of that so I I
I don't want to be
um Charlie Brown trying to kick the
football with Biden Lucy holding it
if I'm you I want to take control of my
life that so for that reason I'm going
to pay it off if I'm you there's another
reason if I'm you but you would have to
decide this reason but if I'm there
that I would pay it off and it is that I
actually borrowed the money I owe it
sure there's that okay that's a big that
that's that's not little that's a big
one
yeah I guess my thought process was
obviously the
the onus of the bills would be on the
taxpayers right that money has to come
from somewhere I guess if I was already
going to be paying higher taxes anyways
I might as well get the benefit yeah and
the guy the guy that welded your car
together that didn't go to college gets
to pay your student loan with his taxes
and teachers who make pennies
have to pay it in taxes it goes to
everybody not just you yeah so I mean
yeah I mean it's
that's the thing so you again you do
whatever you want I'm we're not going to
argue with you about that uh but you did
call here and ask so you're always going
to get you know what we think because
that's the problem with this thing it's
what it's about the show's about what we
think so
um
and you know I Jay there's a a
percentage of
um
uh
idiots out there that are gonna they're
gonna be really really upset and say we
were shaming poor Jacob uh we're not
shaming poor Jacob no at all uh I'm just
telling you what I think I think it's
there's an ethical consideration and if
you think ethics is a form of shaming
then you or what is known as a child
because where do you draw the line Dave
where do you draw the line that's the
question
I mean there are government programs
that are in place
uh that offer tax incentives I take
those I don't pay any more in taxes than
I need to so is that unethical no that's
in place and I didn't promise to do
something and then choose to let the
government do it for me that's right I
have not ever
promised to do anything and then chose
to let the government do it for me but
I've taken advantage of a lot of taxes
tax breaks of all kinds anything that is
on the books and is legal I hate taxes
so um but that that is not an there is a
complete difference here is that I did
not sign up and says I owe this right
now you take care of it but you know
Dave a lot of people on the other side
of it people will say well Dave the
student loan companies they were
predatory they took advantage of me they
took advantage of me an 18 year old kid
absolutely talk to that they're absolute
scum they're absolute scum and um on
that basis if uh we're going to be
righteous and holy and forgive student
loan debt we should buy God quit making
the students
how can you keep making the student
loans and that's taught me in Tennessee
we call it talking about both sides of
your head you know you can't solve a
problem while simultaneously creating it
that's impossible not not without
calling that intellectual dishonesty
right so yeah I mean that which is what
the definition of politics is so there
you go but uh but yeah so I mean
Democrats Republicans alike that you
guys up there if you did anything on the
hill worth doing it would be stop this
program that's right because you're
destroying young lives with it you're
hurting way more people than you're
helping with the Student Loan program if
you don't believe me watch borrowed
future and you'll see the predatory
action so yeah Jacob may have been taken
advantage of in the sense that he was
young dumb and naive like I was and I
did a lot of stupid butt stuff in
college myself
when I was in college because I'd be
canceled like long before it was even
cool to cancel stuff true that but if
you've got them
a thousand of them and you know what we
did Dave you hate them we paid them off
you and big Sam and you did that with
like work and stuff imagine that this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
I'm Dave Ramsey your host at Jade
warshaw Ramsay personality is my co-host
today on the debt free stage in in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions Scott and
Rachel are here hey guys how are you
good hey doing well welcome welcome
where do you guys live
we're from Kingsport Tennessee
absolutely just over the hill well
welcome to Nashville good to have you
here to do a debt free scream how much
did you pay off uh 65k all right good
for you how long did that take
um 18 months good and your range of
income during that time
uh between 60 and 70 up to ending at
105. good for you what do y'all do for a
living I'm a dental assistant
and I at the time
um did Real Estate and
um was operations manager for subsidiary
of summit racing
um and has since taken a procurement
role with a Fortune 500 company in white
sport good for you very cool good so
that explains the increase in income yes
and the um the the side hustle so to
speak with real estate okay and that's
been going good for you good for you
guys what kind of debt was the 65 000.
uh we have a list here
5K on a camper
impulse buy
um
45k in vehicles and 15K student loans
you got a lot of cars yeah what'd you do
with them
um just just hustled with the uh the
real estate side income and got it all
paid off paid them off yes
okay because you were bathing in that
yeah so tell me the story what happened
what got you started on all those crazy
Ramsey stuff
uh kind of the the beginnings were 20 20
a couple things going on
um I was unhappy in my career and we
were expecting
um our first child and I also became
licensed and in real estate at the time
just in time for the pandemic yeah yeah
great timing yeah and uh had and ended
up switching you know main roles as well
and then fast forward the end of 2021 uh
that role was not going so well you know
some some night shift you know wasn't uh
you know nice for family life so I ended
up going back to my old employer for a
small pay cut and I remember
having a conversation with Rachel
um you know
I almost refused to go back because of
the pay cut
and we realized well it's not
necessarily the the money we're making
it's where it's all going that's right
um and you know and there was a little
bit in there you know she had
aspirations to be a stay-at-home mom and
um you know wasn't uh really for her you
know she tried for a bit
um so then at the beginning of 2021 you
know it was conversation of you know hey
if you decided you want to do this you
know I've got this real estate you know
side income let's let's get after it
wow so during this 18 months what was
the hardest part what was the part that
you just were like uh I cannot wait
until this this part of it is over what
was the hardest part
um probably a couple of things the
second job yeah hours yeah I know my son
was you know a newborn
um but and he didn't know I wasn't there
but I did and
um and my wife as well you know there
were days I would I would leave um you
know my main job five six o'clock you
know drive to a town an hour away to
show home and you know I'm back home at
nine or ten o'clock and long days you
know to give credit to my wife you know
she she mentions at times that you know
I was the one kind of hustling and
getting after real estate but I couldn't
have done that without her support you
know to put in those long days and you
know take care of our son how's it feel
to be free that's awesome awesome was it
worth it yeah definitely
so how you gonna buy the next car cash
Bingo
not for a while
how'd you get connected to us
uh when I went back to my previous
employer you know I remember having that
conversation with a a confidant of mine
there you know uh you know I hated to
come back I need I needed that income
and you know I had it calculated out you
know I lost this amount per month and
you know I was kind of nerdy about it
and he said hey you seem you know pretty
dialed into this have you heard of Dave
Ramsey and uh of course you know sorry I
said no
and uh you know he gave me uh your book
and then tuned in the podcast Rachel and
I and
the rest is history there we go very
cool very cool what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt-ish
sticking to it
yep that and a budget a budget budget
and and for me
um personally
um yeah I had to really change the way I
think about money
um
you're not as a vehicle for you know
things but as a tool for you know my
family to leave a legacy and to build a
future Ah that's good it's a good
Viewpoint well done good job you guys
we're proud of you man sure right thank
you mad stuff good stuff hey we've got
the live and give bundle for you we
always give it out to our debt free
screamers the baby steps millionaires
book The Total Money Makeover book now
when you're talking to somebody you can
give it away and Financial Peace
University if you've been through it
well if not oh God take it and take that
and go through it we got a membership
for you and uh you ought to do that
that's great very very cool so proud of
you guys who was your biggest
cheerleaders other than the two of you
we kind of we kind of played it close to
the vest you know I had the colleague at
work there and
um it's funny I may be misremembering I
don't think Rachel recalled but you know
when I started diving into your stuff I
think I recalled that our marriage
counseling
um was actually taught you know had some
lessons from you oh wow okay oh you're
pre-marriage pre-marriage yeah yeah okay
that's possible yeah so and I remember
you know connecting to those and you
know things kind of came back and you
know we just jumped on board very cool
well way to go you two well done very
well done we're proud of you here thank
you for making the trip over to do your
debt free scream we appreciate it Scott
and Rachel Kingsport Tennessee 65
000 paid off in 18 months making 60 to
70 now to 105 that's the way it always
works count it down let's hear a debt
free scream ready three two one yeah
[Music]
all right
well done well done well done
well one of the things you'll find is
that often not with those guys but often
the people doing their debt free screams
have gone through Financial Peace
University 10 million people have now
that's not a couple that's a bunch
and uh making it probably arguably the
largest financial class and current
existence in America today and uh the
most successful by far in terms of the
results that we get we're flooded this
time of year you know it's the end of
January and so your resolution may be a
resolution by now
um it may be time to reset again and go
okay all that bullcrap now let's really
do it let's really do it so you can't
wish for things to change unless you do
something different get plugged into
Financial Peace University you'll learn
The Proven Plan not only to get out of
debt but become a baby steps millionaire
in the process and be outrageously
generous put yourself in a position that
every time eggs go up all these funny
memes about eggs are funny memes
you got three million dollars you're not
whining about eggs
saying
so this is what you do so check it out
we're offering Financial Peace
University right now for 69.99 through
the end of the month which is just a
couple days uh so get this limited time
offer on FPU ramseysolutions.com deal
and uh how do they sign up for your
class well you can it's not a virtual
class right that's right that's right
Dave we're doing a class that starts
March 1st uh James will put that
information on the screen you can use
the QR code to sign up we'll put the
link in the show notes and hey we're
trying to pack this thing out so if you
are waiting to get started if you've
never done FPU before this is your
chance if you were looking for
inspiration accountability this is your
chance to sign up there are no more
excuses I will warn you when I was doing
small groups people cried
now this is Jade doing the small group
and she looks sweet I can make you shed
it looks pretty but she's rather mean
I'll just tell you she's gonna get on
your stuff if you don't mess it it's
just because I love you it's all out of
love that's right she loves to do it
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about life and money Brett is
with us in Provo Utah hi Brett welcome
to the Ramsey Show
oh thanks Dave thanks for having me on
sure what's up
uh so me and my family we have been
renting for the last year while paying
off student loans uh we paid off 115 000
of student loans it's awesome yeah
thank you
um yeah so we're at a point now where
we're looking uh to save up for a down
payment on a house
um
and the house we would be looking to buy
it would take us about three years to to
get a down payment for that house
um but we're wondering if maybe it might
just be smarter to wait another three
years so a total of six years to pay for
a house in cash
how much of a down payment are you doing
in three years fifty percent
yeah it's pretty much close to that yeah
houses are pretty determined 50 is a
down payment
uh just for the house we were looking at
for no I'm saying 100 000. I know you
you said you can do 50 percent
of the house price in three years right
yes
four hundred thousand
uh three yeah I guess 350 is what I was
looking at yeah okay and what do you
make
uh 260. way to go good for you how old
are you gosh
uh I'm 32 and my wife is 29. okay well
this is one of the uh maybe the only
answer
that I ever give here on the air that is
um
not what I would do
but what is okay to do okay what I do
the way I live my life for the last 30
plus years now since I went broke is I
don't borrow money
period for anything
ever
and so I have to
figure out a way to cash flow because
there is nothing that I want badly
enough or that I'm scared enough of to
go in debt for it I have been there done
that I didn't like the T-shirt I'm not
doing it any more okay I truly do
believe that the Bible is telling the
truth that the borrower is slave to the
lender and I truly don't borrow money
and I do believe that that is the
shortest path
to wealth
by the way okay uh the the starting few
years is rough uh but the the ending
years are amazing yeah so uh uh uh now
having said all of that then it's the
only advice we give here on the air that
I don't personally follow and that is if
you take out a mortgage with a good
strong down payment 50 is more than a
good strong a good strong down payment
would be 10 or 15 or something like that
20 would avoid PMI that's good and your
payment on a 15-year fix is no more than
a fourth of your take-home pay if you
did that in your case
you could then pay that house off within
six years
right right and if you could pay cash
for it in six years you could pay it off
in six years and obviously anyone who
pays their home off in six years is way
weird compared to the culture
so you're you're weird no matter where
we are on the Spectrum yeah and you're
and you're heading in the in the you
know your your face is under the column
of smart people no matter what we do on
this spectrum that's right so either one
of those is fine so it's just a matter
of
some would call me a legalist some would
call me a purist uh someone just call me
not a hypocrite but um but that I don't
borrow so you can do either by Ramsay
guidelines anywhere in between those two
things and be there so you could put
down 50 you could put down eighty
percent you can put down twenty percent
on a 15-year fix where the payment's no
more than a fourth year take on pay and
it wouldn't be in this case and then
turn a paid off as fast as you can
all of that is within our guidelines
because we know that that's going to
lead you to wealth Brett how old are you
what do you do for a living
so I'm a nurse anesthetist ah good very
good you're killing it man so yeah that
was where I was kind of having the the
question between the two just because is
it is there any measure on if it's
harder for kids to move when they're
older that was kind of what we were
going between two I mean I wouldn't want
to wait I wouldn't want to move in high
school if that's what you're asking I
think that kids are very resilient I
think that by the time they you know
once they put down Roots if you get into
those high school years it can be a
little bit tough but I mean you can
recover from anything but yeah when
they're how you have you've got kids now
how
so the oldest is seven so seven five and
three seven they're all right she would
be
13 you know if we waited the full six
years to to pay well that's also
assuming you get absolutely no increases
in income right
right yeah yeah I yeah true that's a
good point which is weird because when I
start saving towards something that I
want really bad what I'll do is work my
butt off yeah and my income goes up and
you know I'm able to just attack it and
so my guess is that it won't take you as
long as the math on a straight line
without any increases in Pay says okay
that you should have because your
intensity will go up and your income
will probably go up both during this
time so it'll probably be four or five
years but same thing's true of paying
the house off
yeah yeah if you bought it and we're
living in it so uh we're not going to
yell at you for either one
um uh uh
I just love the options that you're
looking at I love that you're calling in
here talking about 50 down or 100 down
that's a wonderful quandary to be in
you've got options you got your head in
the right place that's for sure and so
again I truly do believe these
principles and so I truly believe that
if I live them I'm going to be the
safest
in the event of a pandemic I'm sitting
in a building that's worth I don't know
what's this thing worth now three four
hundred three or four hundred million
dollars and advice and paid for and paid
for and so nobody I didn't have to worry
during the pandemic that we couldn't
make the payments here yeah okay is that
that allows this bald head to lay on a
pillow and sleep
you know it just is a different world
Joe's in Greensboro North Carolina Hey
Joe how are you
hey David hey AJ how are you
oh great thank you so much for taking my
call
um our question is
I'm kind of
I own a business my father just passed
away so we're still navigating the
situation I'm sorry how long ago did he
pass
Ed New Years sorry to hear that
and oh thank you and it's it's trying to
get everything together and I can't slow
down I'm you know I've got my foot to
the Huddle trying to get this business
in the right direction still and recruit
them from losing him he's a vital part
of it but our main question is is well
we do have debt for the company I've
been personally working on the baby
steps for over a year now I'm like on
baby step three because I gotta attack
my daughter's College because I
neglected that for so long
um so now I'm torn between do I focus on
the business debt or focus on my debt
you signed for the best business debt
it's all your debt legally it's all
personal debt how much is it
605 000.
yes okay what's the business making
what's your income
uh about 5.5
million dollars Top Line
yes what are you netting
uh
okay I couldn't I couldn't tell you that
off top of my head okay that's your next
new job when you get off the phone is
learn your numbers to run your business
okay you need to know what your numbers
are as an entree leader I'm going to say
small business to small business you
don't stay open if you don't learn your
numbers and stay on them you need to
know what you're making all the time
that needs to be like top of mind it's
not because your money obsessed it's
because money's the scorecard that tells
you the health of your business
and tells you whether you've got a
disease inside there or not okay so you
got to figure that out what did you pay
taxes on last year what was your income
tax filing on how much money
foreign
your personal income tax oh personal
personal I'm sorry I was thinking about
business
um 100
yeah your business did not make 4.8
million and you only personally made a
hundred something's wrong with your
equation there if you're making a profit
of a million dollars a year it's
both often shut up okay if you're making
a profit of a hundred thousand dollars a
year then you need to prioritize your
debts at home and get rid of the small
ones first and then we'll work on the
605 and that's the way it is but you
need to figure out what your money you
got to work with you can't even tell us
that puts us out of the Ramsey Show in
the books
[Music]
deeper dive on your money Journey we
have a Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm your host Dave Ramsey
Jade warshaw from Ramsay personality is
my co-host today we'll be taking your
questions at triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in and we'll
talk triple eight eight two five five
two two five Sean's in Wichita Falls
Texas hey Sean how are you
I'm doing good how are you Dave better
than I deserve what's up
all right so about a year ago me and my
wife we were expecting our uh second
child so we sold our house and upgraded
this to a little bit bigger of a home
for a growing family and so I now
um you know with everything being kind
of a buyer's market and all
um I am actually relocated or relocating
from my job and so we don't know how
much Equity we would actually get we've
talked to some Realtors and feel like we
would probably maybe just get back what
we put in
um and didn't know if relocating
um if we should rent out our house or if
we should just go ahead and sell it even
though uh we may not get much back
where are you moving to
um Abilene Texas
how far is that from Wichita Falls
it's about uh two and a half hours yeah
um I I want to Circle back to the part
where you have real estate agents
telling you your house has not gone up
in value
and that this is a buyer's market
um it's not a buyer's market it's a
seller's market there's a shortage of
inventory the white hot sales of 83
offers over the weekend are gone thank
god
um but houses are selling there are more
buyers than there are
sellers which by definition makes it a
seller's market the rate of sale the
number of sales is slowed because some
people are sitting on the sidelines in
terms of buying but your house has not
dove in value when did you buy this
house
we bought it um just about a year ago
February uh 2022. okay you might not
make enough in one year
to cover the expenses you might come out
less than you out of pocket and what
what you put in you might not get all of
that back out a net of expenses because
the house would have had to go up 10 in
value to cover expenses one year later
okay so it's in a normal real estate
market selling a house one year later is
unusual to make money
in a normal Market
okay and that's more what we're in today
than we were 18 months ago 24 months ago
this is more of a normal market in terms
of the rate of time it takes to sell the
house and so forth so that does uh I'll
back off then and say your real estate
agents may be giving you actual good
information and and by you know that
telling you it's going to take a little
while to sell the house it always has
except for around a thing called a
pandemic but other than that it for 30
years I've had my real estate license it
takes 90 to 120 days to sell a house
except for a short period of time there
when you you know a monkey could sell a
house in 20 minutes but um
those days are gone hopefully it's not
good for the economy for when it gets
quite hot like that so anyway uh but
it's but it would have been good for you
it would have been nice so here's the
thing you do not want a long-distance
landlord two and a half hours away sell
it even if you lose some money the the
job you took is there more money
um yeah just a little bit why are you
going
um I am taking a youth faster job so
um I've been working for a organization
called Fellowship of Christian athletes
I mean missionary funded so
um it was just kind of a thing that I
did for a year and now we feel like
God's leading us back to the church
um so because so you were you were
pastoring and then you went on a
missionary status with FCA which is
their normal methodology and then you
decide to go back on staff and move to
Abilene
yes okay cool cool good for you and what
are you gonna be making
um right now
um we're still working out some of the
details for probably about 50 000. good
okay good for you okay yeah please sell
the house
you cannot afford a five or a ten
thousand dollar problem with a house two
and a half hours away because you can't
keep your fingers on it
it's a it's a liability it's not an
asset
that's right and not only that but the
Temptation is going to be if you were to
keep that house then you go over here
and move to Abilene you're going to want
to buy a house there and before you know
you're going to have two mortgages
you're gonna be and you're going to be
out of order on the baby steps so yet
another reason to sell the house save up
your kind of back at baby step 3B at
this point yeah yeah the blessings of
the Lord have no sorrow added to them
the psalmist says and so when you look
at this house two years from now are you
going to consider it a blessing when
you've been trying to rent it two and a
half hours away the answer is no
rental investment real estate is a good
plan not when you're broke and not when
you got no equity which means the house
probably won't even rent far enough to
cover the payments so you need to sell
this house even if you don't get out as
much as you put in net of expenses so
good question Sean thank you for being
sensitive to the Lord's leading well
done Nathan's with us in Wisconsin hi
Nathan welcome to Ramsey Show
hey Dave how is she going better than we
deserve brother what's up
beautiful so I know the normal order of
the baby steps but I have a 14 mortgage
that is variable rate good Lord so I'm
wondering if I should hit that first why
are your credits suck
because I'm really dumb and really
wanted the house it was 11 horrible but
I'm gonna do this right pay it off in
three years and then I didn't then you
didn't so is your credit bad
yeah I was never great and now I ended
up with an employer disappearing on me
so now it's really crashed after two
months of paying everything late
okay so you can't refinance
no
how much do you owe on the house
34 000 oh not a ton okay like a car
payment but a bad one okay yeah and so
what do you make
I make around 55
how much other debt do you have
what's before this I owe 17K on the
Coyote Tractor and another 60k on some
family land
you have a 17 000 tractor and a thirty
four thousand dollar house
does that not sound Wicked weird do you
it does to me
yeah I want to do shiny at the
dealership and shouldn't tell them I'm
probably going to sell it in the spring
yeah I think you need to sell it I think
that thing needs to go away and so 17
034 what was the other one 60k on land
around 60 000 on land
that you don't live on part of a family
farm a part of a family farm so you
bought into when somebody died
uh it was due to my dad's financial
situation it would either buy it or lose
it
okay
um Nathan you need you need to stop
doing impulsive crap you need to change
three of these purchases were bad ideas
and you see the pattern brother yeah
sell the tractor and uh take six jobs
and pay off your house and uh dad needs
to get his crap together and buy the
land back so you don't have that debt
quit making impulsive financial
decisions you're going broke brother
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today every year at tax time
it's the same old story a boatload of
people wait until the last minute
scramble to get their taxes done on time
and folks you're smarter than that
there are benefits to filing early for
starters it means you can get ahead of
any surprises and give yourself time to
make a plan if you end up owing money to
the IRS
so once you've got your W-2s your 1099s
from your employer you should be what
you should have gotten by an hour any
second now go ahead and knock out your
taxes if you like to file on your own
you can get all your ducks in a row
e-file with confidence using Ramsey
smart tax it's our No Nonsense online
tax software created to help you win
with money Ramsay smart tax gives you
everything you need to file your tax
return and you'll know exactly what
it'll cost up front no hidden fees no
sneaky agendas and you get a deal you
save up to 70 percent if you switch to
Ramsey smart tax from a leading
competitor go to ramsaysolutions.com
smart tax and get your taxes in your
rear view mirror ramseysolutions.com
smart text
Jade um our last caller
um
I've been that guy I've known that guy
my whole life
and um
the Bible says he who is impulsive
exalts folly
now that's a proverb from the wisdom
literature now let's talk about that
impulsive exalts Folly Folly is the verb
of a Fool In Action when I am impulsive
I am lifting up
a Fool In Action I'm exalting it
I am worshiping it I am becoming it and
um so uh when we make particularly large
decisions
impulsively
um
you know here's what's interesting I
know nerds who will spend
days studying Consumer Reports studying
manufacturer ratings
specifications all to spend a thousand
or two thousand dollars on something
like a computer sure and then impulse a
fifty thousand dollar car
it doesn't make sense
but they do it and I'll tell you one of
the most one of the most things that
Americans impulse the largest things
that we buy that goes down in value and
one of the things that we impulse worse
than anything else is cars and these
cars have gotten people in trouble you
you went off on this last week and your
little uh trash and going after people
for being stupid with 1300 car payments
has gone viral something like 10 million
people saw the clip already uh it's wild
and then Bloomberg comes out today and
says uh Americans are falling behind on
car payments at a higher rate than any
time three times as bad as 2009. well I
wonder what recession I wonder why Dave
because people are taking these notes it
says there's a growing cohort of
Americans facing Auto repossessions this
is an ominous sign for the U.S economy
during the pandemic a surge in you used
car prices
forced yes
to take out bigger loans and that right
there forced yep you were forced that's
the word you didn't have a choice well
here's the thing on that that you had to
have a 74 000 Raptor and so you were
forced and that's what I saw Dave if you
look at the comments on that post that
is what people are saying
what was our choice your choice is don't
be stupid that's your choice that's your
choice don't be stupid try not being
stupid that's a good choice and then and
then the other side of it the other side
of reality like you said the people who
chose to go against the grain are saying
hey you know I just bought a car in cash
that I could afford it's getting me from
point A to point B and when the right
time comes I upgrade so there there is a
cohort of Americans who do have the
right idea Dave there's there's some
smart people there are some people
there's some stupid people yeah there's
a lot of stupid people Dave 85 percent
of Americans have car notes 80 and of
those 85 percent of Americans
15 of them have a car note of a thousand
dollars or more it's just hard to wrap
one thousand
I just can't even get my head around
that
so here's the thing if you put that as
Jay did in a calculator and talked about
it last week in that piece that went
viral if you invest a car payment for
just a couple of decades you will have
over a million dollars you'll have five
million dollars if you do it for three
decades thank you and so I don't have
the money say for my kids Kyle just
cause you're stupid and you put all your
money in a car payment that's why you
got no money you're stupid and can you
talk to the people Dave because I try to
tell them I try to tell them I said I
said the same thing you said and you
know what they said to me where are you
getting a 10 rate of return who's going
to invest their money over 30 years Jade
and you want to know what the answer is
millionaires millionaires that's how
people make their money if you're
listening and you don't understand that
this is not a car problem this is a YOLO
problem you only live once
oh you sweet little child listen adults
devise a plan and follow it children do
what feels good Bingo very few people
who are successful are whiners
they don't walk around with a big V on
their forehead that says victim I'm so I
can't get it I want a car that's safe oh
shut up they roll up their sleeves and
they work seriously there's people here
who roll up their sleeves and work there
are actual people in the world who will
set aside a portion of their income for
20 30 years and invest it into their
401K into their IRA and they become
millionaires that's what we call them we
hear them every day on the air so for
all of those people they weren't forced
to do that they weren't forced but for
all of these folks out here yakety yakin
talking Yak talk about oh you can't get
a 10 rate of return where here's what I
kept hearing what stocks give you an
annual rate of 10 return the stock
market has averaged 11.8 percent since
it began hello and if David 500 that's
the average on it since it began 11.
average for for 80 years you dumbbell
but this is not hard we're sitting here
telling you you got Dave Ramsey who's
got more money than anybody you know and
then Forbes Magazine tells us the number
one payment keeping people broke is
their car note it's not just us so if
you want to think it's just oh it's just
Ramsey Solutions they're the only one
they're the only folks out here saying
this that is not the case the case is 85
percent of people have cars here's the
thing 67 percent of people are living
whining and work
what a concept what you'll have is is
the ability to sacrifice to win see
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good here's the
thing so when I went broke
we lost everything
we had one car with a payment on it
re I I reaffirmed it out of bankruptcy
and I'm paying my paying my payment
paying my paying my payment
and my wife would have left but we only
had one car
and so I mean we were we were we're mad
we were hurt we were wounded
whining like some of you people are
and a guy loaned me a car because I
refused to I that's it I'm not borrowing
any more money he loaned me a 1978
Cadillac with 478 000 actual miles
aren't the predominant color on it was
Bondo
the vinyl roof was torn loose across the
front so when you drove it it filled up
with air looked like a parachute
I'm driving a Bondo buggy with a
parachute on top now you know what I was
driving before that before I went broke
a jaguar
I went from Jaguar to parachute Bondo
buggy because you know what happens when
you go broke you don't care what other
people think they don't care
I lost my need to impress your butt at a
stoplight
and so I go into a nice neighborhood and
that car the cops are following me think
I'm there to rob somebody and so I got
profiled based on my car can you imagine
that I can and so uh you know so I'm
a drove like no one else and I saved up
and I paid cash for a thousand dollar
car which is an incredible upgrade and
gave my buddy his Blessing back that he
had loaned me
and then we move on to the next one
right and we save up and we buy a three
thousand dollar car and we save up and
we buy a ten thousand dollar car you
know I drove like no one else so now I
drive anything I freaking want Come On
Come On Dave seriously y'all need to
know what it feels like to work
and stop your whining it's not becoming
the wussification of America the things
you think you have to have to survive is
sickening it's sickening for a short
period of time pay a price to win no one
wins without paying a price the repo
rate on you idiots right now is three
times what it was in 2009 in the Great
Recession it's the worst repo rate we've
seen in 30 years stop it
foreign
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today Brock
and Rachel are with us they are on the
debt-free stage right here in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions hey guys what's up
hey welcome where do you all live in
Houston Houston Texas welcome to
Nashville how much debt have you paid
off 500
000.
how long did this take five years 60
months to the day wow awesomeness and
what was your income range during that
time uh started about 160 and ended
about 220. wow that's incredible what
kind of debt was this that you paid off
oh let me tell you a lot of ignorance
are you getting on the list out of your
pocket yes ma'am this is a five-year
list that we kept oh my goodness it was
two homes credit cards
um a loaned by her a wedding band uh a
new HVAC system for our house a new car
some floors okay living life you were
normal yeah
wow so what was the wake-up call 60
exact months ago we got married oh um we
came we both came into marriage with
different amounts of debt and we just
realized that that's not what we wanted
to build our marriage on and we wanted
to have more fun yeah so I love that our
church decided to bring you on a board
for FPU and sure enough the light went
off at that point very cool what church
you go to Second Baptist oh yeah okay
cool cool yeah we had a big deal there
yes sir yes sir we were there yeah very
good good for y'all show you that that
that church doing Financial Peace
University Church wide got you guys
plugged in absolutely and about the time
that you wanted to be anyway yes sir we
were dating at the time and so we were
actually in separate small groups um but
having really good conversations on
afterwards of what we wanted our life to
look like if we got married and so that
was our how much later were you married
after that less than a year yeah okay it
was real quick but I will be honest with
you it took about a year before I
finally got mad enough to actually do
something the right way I was gonna ask
were you both immediately on board or
was somebody so she was she was you were
the reluctant one I'm the spender so you
know hey I want to keep buying oh okay
so how did you how did you whoop that
out of him Rachel I didn't I did it with
a lot of conversations my parents um did
Financial Peace University and so they
gave me the book I think in college if
not right after and I was like this is
cute but I'm good and it wasn't until we
realized that we were having to deal
with debt and deciding what we were
going to do with our money and if we
were going to be dictated by our debt or
if we were actually going to prepare a
life for our kids one day that we wanted
and so it really was doing it
um together that we decided like we have
to do this but then a year later it came
down to I don't know what huge hit
happened oh it I looked at her and she's
about three months away from giving
birth to our first son and I said this
ain't happening no more yeah oh the baby
coming that's a wake-up call ding ding
yeah this just got real oh yeah yeah and
I'm not gonna settle her and surely I
will saddle him with my ignorance right
there you go so we fixed it quick you
know I love that so there you go you
guys this is amazing yeah and not you
know I told her the other uh probably
back in November uh it got pretty tough
there at the end as you can imagine you
see the light at the end of the tunnel
but that tunnel seems to get longer and
longer
and uh we just did a few numbers and we
realized we had a really good income but
we were only living on fifty thousand
dollars a year wow everything went to
the dead and so you mean you can
actually live on less than you make
and we did
you know our friends they live high on
the hog and yeah we thought we were
weird we were now that you know Ramsay
was weird but it is we we felt like we
were missing out now I wouldn't change
it for the world you were missing out
yep you were you were missing out on
stupid yeah and I was a teacher before I
stayed home with our boys and so I
always thought well I don't have the
income to do this I don't have enough
money to save or enough money to truly
get out of debt and it wasn't until we
realized like how much money we were
actually spending that we didn't have
that I could have done that years before
and so that's one thing I regret not
doing it sooner yeah and I've told her a
number of times you know I wish that
wouldn't have been that stupid but prior
to knowing her and settling her with
mine
sure that's okay that's okay the trick
is the change the trick is the
transformation which we've both gone
through so did you say this is house and
everything yes sir wow y'all are so
weird yeah on December 30th her the two
boys all four of us walked into Wells
Fargo and said get out my house okay we
broke up
and we had all the bankers come out and
they said this isn't normal I said good
because I ain't never coming back so how
long has it been since you made that
final mortgage payment it is one month
today so you're feeling it now you're
starting to feel that good wow what's
your first big thing y'all are gonna do
come in here this was our trip I mean
after this yeah oh gosh after this you
don't have any payments no we don't um
actually one thing that we talked about
when we were redoing our budget of okay
how much we want to put towards savings
like this is our new income we don't
have debt how much we want to do and we
realize that we really want to put that
money back into savings
um to buy him a car soon because he's
driving one of those reliable old cars
13 years old yeah you need to get
another car so I want that um but we
also wanted to put a line in our budget
of just giving of being able to like pay
for someone's meal you know or buy
groceries for somebody and not feel like
well now we don't have that money to do
something and so we put a line item in
our budget of just being able to spoil
other people random acts of kindness yes
I think both of our parents did an
amazing job of teaching us the joy that
you get from giving good and I think
that's what I'm most excited about going
forward in the next five ten years is
like The Best Is Yet To Come for our
boys
um of like the life that we get to do
with them but then how we get to teach
them to be generous they teach them to
hear God whisper yeah and say take care
of that lady over there yeah we actually
have a thing we say I read it in a book
and it's look for the god links along
the way yeah oh that's good that's good
yeah that's a good word yeah well done
y'all well done I'm so proud of you
thank you how's it feel to be completely
free really good I was telling him this
trip has been hard because I'm so used
to Counting pennies and like well are we
on are we on our budget have we spent
too much and and it's been nice just to
relax and enjoy our income so that's
been fun it's it's fun to to know we're
okay to know I'm not going to make her
hurt by doing something a little too
much or a little too little and it I
will tell you the last month was really
tough at work and then to walk in
January 2nd and say I don't care what
happens I'll go push carts around at
Lowe's and be just as happy now because
I don't have to pay anybody anymore
changes the way you work changes the
motivation behind yes because I want to
be there now yeah yeah you got a choice
now yes sir well done y'all thank you
what do you tell me people the key to
getting out of debt is
doing it together
I think if we hadn't been on the same
page and had the same vision it wouldn't
have happened and I was I was lucky
enough that I had parents that
introduced me to this whole concept
before but then I had a sweet friend
Kelly that through our single days of
all of the weddings and all the
bridesmaids dresses that we had to buy
and all of that she was the one that
would eat before we would go out to eat
and she would eat chips and salsa and
that's it because that was not in her
budget that month and it gave me the
support of like someone else is doing it
I can do it too and so I would just say
to find someone to do it with because
then you don't feel like you're on an
island you're doing it together yeah you
know and for me when I said it took
about a year till I got mad and it's
it's the age-old adage that everyone has
said I got sick and tired of being sick
and tired decided to draw a line in the
sand yes ma'am change your life way to
go y'all way to go hey we've got the
live and give bundle for you the baby
steps millionaires book The Total Money
Makeover book and another Financial
Peace University membership that'll help
you with your generosity plan thank you
you'll be able to give those and catch
somebody and get them going get them
motivated moving and you're they can
have the same story you've had or their
version of your story so way to go y'all
thank you you're while we come down here
you're inspiring very very well done
Brock and Rachel Houston Texas 500 000
paid off in 60 months that's five years
for those of you that are counting and
they did that 100 house and
no payments anywhere 160
000 to 200 000 income living on 50.
count it down let's hear it free scream
ready three two one
[Applause]
I don't know where those people live
they have paid four cars in a paid for
house
next door to you that's where they live
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host Alexander is
in Philadelphia hi Alexander welcome to
the Ramsay show
Hi how are you thank you for taking my
call I appreciate your time sure what's
up
um so I want to buy a garage ornament
and I want to be on the smart side of
the spectrum and have a conversation
with you before I end up on the stupid
side of the stuff
okay how expensive a car
all said and done everything it's about
thousand dollars cool what do you make
uh take home with me and my wife it's
about uh 14 000 a month with net
so 150 Grand
whatever that is probably close to 200
yeah okay
all right um as far as debt is concerned
Why don't you ask the question that's
okay we're back here that's good that's
okay how much debt
uh 150 000. on what
uh my house okay
and um what's your uh nest egg
how much money you got I got about had
eight hundred thousand in retirement I
got about four hundred and thirty
thousand dollars
um you know in liquid assets I guess I
have two sons and I have about ninety
thousand dollars in each of their 529
plans okay so the rule of thumb I use on
uh toys
which you're at the level of toy on this
um yeah and I've got some toys so the
rule of thumb I use and that I teach I'm
a guy it's in my DNA okay I don't have a
car hey man I have a Subaru like I had
enough you're gonna pay cash for this
car right I'm gonna do it you tell me I
mean you say you know okay if you're if
you're not gonna pay cash for it don't
do it
number one rule okay number two rule is
cars go down in value things with motors
and things with wheels cars boats sea
Doos they're sisters
um I've got a bunch of things that go
wooden wooden and I like stuff like that
but they all lose value
and so we don't want to have a general
rule of thumb is you're a millionaire
okay A little over a million dollar net
worth
um if I understood the numbers correctly
and
um and it sounds like you make a couple
hundred a year
the trick is we use a rule of thumb that
says don't don't buy things with cars
with motors and wheels all total
including your other car your Subaru
other stuff like that that equal more
than half your annual income because
they go down and we want to have small
amounts of things going down in our life
now you've got an unusually high net
worth you're paying cash for this you're
probably going to violate that 50
percent
when you buy it
okay matter of fact we know you are
because you make about 200 a year and
you're going to spend 130 just on this
one car and your other cars on top of
that are going to put you over that
um normally I would say that's a no-go
it kind of makes me question it here
um
a little bit
what's your question well I mean I just
don't want to put too much in things
that go down in value and I'm trying to
look at the ratios of your net worth
it's like uh not to you know it is a g
it is a Nissan GTR I don't know if you
know anything about Nissan GTRs but
they're very very very hard to find and
if you go on auto a Trader or something
like that right now
um they're they're astronomically priced
even in the used Market likelihood if
you're the new rapper the new one the
new Raptor just came out 700 horsepower
um they're running about 120. okay but
they're not going to go up in value
I understand even though they're like
they're much like your Nissan that
you're talking about that yeah I've
looked at that car it's a very sweet car
um and so yeah you can you can do it but
what you've got to realize is you've put
a little bit more into a depreciating
asset because 10 years from now let's
face it that thing's not going up in
value
no no I mean I've got a 60 a 1960
Corvette that's frame up restoration
that is fabulous and I've had it for
probably 10 years I don't think it's
gone up a diamond value I don't think
it's gone down any but it might it might
have gone up a little bit
but uh the classic cars some of them
like that some of them will go up a
little or a super super rare item you
know that you can't get like stuff
that's running off the auto auction that
kind of stuff the rare car auctions
sometimes those will go up in value and
but I don't think your Nissan's going to
qualify and I don't think that raptor is
going to qualify for that so anyway all
that to say the way I'm not going to
tell you what to do the way I make
decisions is am I putting too much of my
asset base and things that are going
down rather than up and normally our
guideline is a pay cash B don't have
total of more than 50 percent of your
household income in there now an
exception of that would be let's say
let's say you called in you had eight
million dollars in mutual funds and your
household income was a hundred thousand
well we wouldn't hold to that 50 of the
hundred thousand right
because you could afford to buy the
thing for 130 if you had eight million
dollars and drive it off a cliff
tomorrow and you wouldn't even notice
financially
right that's the point so you're right
on that you don't have eight million but
you got a million and a half probably we
didn't talk about your house Equity but
um you know you're right on that and
you're doing great so you're you're not
going to go bankrupt because of this but
I wouldn't go buy another one Alex no no
this is this is this is it for me I mean
I don't I don't I haven't I don't drive
a fancy car
um you're about to not really like that
but I just uh I've always liked this car
for the last you know however many years
it's a sweet it's a sweet vehicle I just
don't want to you know I think I I you
know I respect everything that you say
you obviously are in the Mana position
for a reason so I just didn't want to
you know well you get the principles I'm
using yeah I understand I completely
understand what you're saying and so I
based on those principles you're on the
bubble you wouldn't be on the dumb side
um you know if your net worth was 500
000 I'd say don't do it
okay yeah my house is worth a pretty
good amount of money too and I don't owe
that much on the house like I said only
a 150 on the house
uh I would I just had my real estate
agent look today he said a million six a
million seven okay so your net worth
three million
so yeah
okay I feel like that moves the needle
that does move the needle that moves it
in your favor see you see what I'm
talking about here that's the whole
thing I just don't we can rationalize
our butts off and I appreciate you
calling I appreciate the spirit you're
being humble about it you're not being
smarter like you're not being sarcastic
you really didn't want to know that
house threw it over the edge in my book
you're okay then yeah I'm good I'm
sleeping good tonight Alexander if you
buy this this car and I'm happy for you
and she's the one that just yelled at
all of America so just keep in mind that
that issue that 130 000 car you've got
he's got over two million dollars in net
worth three three yeah definitely get it
and get me one too I'm just kidding
there you go that is a sweet vehicle
y'all look it up if you haven't looked
it up oh man all right that's so that's
the thing and these numbers do change
you know here's an example okay
everybody says okay what percentage of
my income should I spend on food well if
we give you a percentage
that's true for people that make a
hundred thousand what if somebody made a
million that's right you don't need to
spend that much on food
because they'd be large
and in charge okay okay I mean so
percent you know these things skew out
if you have a very low income you're you
know very poor okay you're just barely
getting started you have to spend a
larger percentage of your income on food
that's right so you know to to just meet
Necessities so these things skew out the
principles that we give you skew out
based on net worth based on income being
at extremes and a three million dollar
net worth is an extreme in America today
God's very successful way to go
Alexander yeah I'm happy for him you
know the thing is you just got to get
these principles down quit buying 50 000
cars when you make fifty thousand
dollars and you got no money right
that's just straight up stupid that's
the point of these principles and he's
not even anywhere he's not even in that
on the in that same book that's the same
chapter or the same page well that's the
point you know Dave we yell at people a
lot for doing dumb stuff but we're
equally happy for the people who have
worked hard they've got the money then
yeah spend your money money is fun to
spend it's fun to give save and spend
it's fun to enjoy it's fun to enjoy and
I think people think that we have
forgotten that but we have not forgotten
that it is fun to spend no I I'm I've
been able to buy some of the things in
my life that I always wanted since I was
a little bitty kid you know I've got
Mastercraft ski boats yeah it's
unbelievably expensive boat but that's
when I was a little kid and that sounds
like a fast boat we got to ski behind
the Mastercraft the first time and run
the slalom course I thought man if I
ever if I ever make it I'm gonna give me
a message so I got me a message I mean
that's how this works look at that there
you go this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
ER you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm your host Dave Ramsey
Jake warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions you jump in the phone number's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five as a reminder if you love this show
leave a five star review mama said if
you ain't got nothing nice to say don't
say nothing at all so we appreciate you
doing that and those of you that listen
on podcasts or YouTube subscribe and
share the show and if you're listening
on uh talk radio like millions of you do
spread the word that's also sharing just
say hey here's where I listen to talk
look here's the talk radio station to
listen to here's when they're on be sure
and do that and a reminder the show is
going to become broadcast as well uh one
hour a day of it uh at five o'clock on a
TBN beginning next week and so uh you'll
be able to pick it up there as well so
we're we're just like uh everywhere
that's what we do so help us spread the
word share it rate it subscribe it all
that kind of stuff helps and if you want
to pay us back for having helped you
that's how you do it you tell people
about it that's how the show grows we
don't have 300 million dollars to spend
on Advertising like Sofi there won't be
a Stadium named after us
or nerd wallet we're not going to spend
the money they spend just to be famous
we're going to be famous by helping you
and you spreading the word so thank you
for that thank you thank you thank you
you're what got us here and you're what
will take us there so that's what we
exist for Jake is with us to start off
this hour Jake's in Tampa Florida hi
Jake how are you hi Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up me too
so I've got a question me and my fiance
are getting married in May yay you know
we're yeah thank you how old are you
we're combining uh 22 we're both 22.
very cool
um so we're combining our um our assets
and our finances and whatnot and I'm
mainly all my investments are in the S P
500 and 401K hers is spread out with
like single stocks
um
so my idea and my thinking was I wanted
to get it into S P 500 maybe a couple
mutual funds and not the single stocks
because
you know she's up right now with them
but you know the S P 500 something that
you can just leave your money in and let
it grow
how much is it in single stocks
about 45 Grand 45 very good for you well
it's great that y'all are talking about
this ahead of time it's very well done
and your play would be better than her
play agreed the S P 500 uh an index fund
would be a better play
um I don't personally use the S P 500
for my 401k nor do we recommend it
um instead we've actually picked mutual
funds that as a group will outperform
the S P 500 and there are a number of
funds that do outperform it there are a
number of funds that don't so you have
to look carefully and get some people in
your corner to help you do that but um I
we spread our investments across four
types in retirement accounts growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
International
full disclosure I use an S P 500 to park
money in Way Beyond having been 100 debt
free Way Beyond having a million dollar
net worth Way Beyond having uh my 401ks
and IRAs fully funded in the four types
I'm talking about but like when I'm
saving up for five years or three years
or two years for a piece of real estate
I'll just throw money in there to park
it short term like a savings account
long-term savings account not I wouldn't
do it for two months but I mean for for
a period of time because I can make more
on it then you're gonna make a stupid
you know CD or something so but I don't
I don't use it for retirement around
here we've always said be across those
four types
so then we could move her money into
some of those four types
what we teach is 25 on each growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international and you know look at look
for long track records and if you're
pulling up the data on them on the
website it's going to show an s p
overlay on it
it's going to say here this fund a fund
XYZ here's what it's performed for the
past 25 years or past 15 years and
here's what the s p has done and if it
doesn't beat the s p for God's sakes
don't do it just do an s p right right
yeah of course Jake what's your wife's
take on this when you've talked about it
what's her reaction
um she's I mean she's ready to do it
she's um you know we've talked a lot
about money and you know we know each
other's finances we're completely
debt-free because she went to college
debt free I never went to college we
have a pretty decent income too what is
that um what's your income
about
160 to 180 wow I'm in sales so it goes
ups and downs when it's combined that's
when it's combined that's what it'll be
you're 22 years old 100 debt for you
make 180k y'all are gonna be so freaking
rich
that's not scary that's a wonderful
place to be James but it's a
responsibility you have to be careful
yeah and cautious and you're wise to do
that so basically what we're saying is
the S P 500 is what's called passive
investing
and there's a whole group of people that
believe in that because some mutual
funds don't outperform it and that's
fine it's just I I think you can do
better and I but full disclosure I use
both and so I'm my portfolio that I'm
outlining would have if you're not real
careful would have more risk than yours
but a lot less than hers
and so that's kind of where we're kind
of over on your side of the coin there
but just past you a little bit okay and
then she's way over there you know in
the high risk stuff with the stocks so
yeah I'm getting out of single stocks
and I'm going to be in mutual funds
preferably across those four that
outperform the s p if not be in the s p
I like it that's what I would do that is
what I do and it does work I mean you
can you can look at the data the uh the
millionaire data that from the
millionaire study that we did that's uh
we put the white paper on it in the back
of the baby steps Millionaire's book so
if you want to read the whole study it's
back there
um but what we found is as the typical
millionaire it's it's doing their 401k
and truthfully if he just does the s p
he's easily going to be there with this
he'll be fine easily easily
um the single stocks just have way too
much risk for me I don't like the risk
of it and the data on people that buy
and sell single stocks is they don't
they don't outperform right so the rule
of thumb with single stocks would be
keep it a very very very low percentage
of your world if you were going to
dabble in them exactly yeah yeah we say
10 Max of your net worth so like if you
work at a place and you really believe
you work for apple and you really
believe it's going to be a great stock
which is a great stock you know
and you want to buy that as a long-term
as an employee benefit you're going to
buy you get most most places give you 15
discount as a employee buying stock so
you're just dying to own some Apple
stock and you're an apple executive well
that's fine just don't let it be more
than 50 more than about 10 of your net
worth because years ago Jade I was
coaching a lady it's really sad she'd
work for Procter Gamble for um many many
years like I don't know 30 or 40 years
and she'd moved all of her 401K money
into Procter Gamble stock and she was
just retiring about the time it went
down it went down like 40 percent so she
had like 700 000 that turned into like
300. they're so 400 000 I mean it went
it went almost in half and it just uh
that's that lack of diversification
though left her susceptible to that
that's what it amounts to this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today so I just saw I feat
Babylon B popped up in my feed that uh
payday lenders have now set up on the
egg aisle
a price of eggs is making headlines you
know you're dealing with a wacky economy
but even news about layoffs and on and
again off again recession crazy high
interest rates this is a weird time
we're in right now and we're here to
give you a plan for your money so we
want you to join us for our Building
Wealth live tour as we show you how to
build wealth and keep it George camel
Rachel Cruz Jade warshaw will be in
Indianapolis in just a couple of weeks
February the 16th then Ken Coleman Dr
John deloney Jade warshaw and I will be
in Austin on February the 23rd next is
Building Wealth Salt Lake City April
24th with George Rachel and Christina
Ellis and finally we're closing out the
tour in Anaheim on May the second Ken
Coleman Dr John deloney and Christine
Ellis tickets are only 49 for each of
these events come out we would love to
have you these events are exciting
they're fun if you're part of the tribe
it's kind of like coming to the pep
rally yeah absolutely that
it's you just you just want to come out
and just be with other people that are
trying to win with money and they're you
know that are doing weird things not
normal like the crazy people in the
culture and you don't want to be
conformed to this world you want to be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
and that's what we're doing we're going
to show you how to win at even in all of
this weird wacky stuff that's going on
and show you how to not panic facts are
your friends when you got this stuff
going on so go to ramseysolutions.com
events get your tickets only 49 for
Indianapolis Austin uh Salt Lake City
and of course Anaheim May the second so
that's our schedule for that particular
live event that's going to be running
all over the place this spring exciting
and July is with us in Odessa Texas hi
Angela welcome to the Ramsay show
Hi how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
so I I have a quick question
we are 26
have is our Home Mortgage which sits at
169 000. and we currently have about a
little over 11 000 into cryptocurrency
and our question was what would be the
next step would we leave it there or
would we take it out and invest that
money somewhere else
well if I'm you I am not going to stay
invested in crypto the track record has
been poo poo uh over the Long Haul so I
would take that money out almost
instantly are you guys investing in
401ks or IRAs anything for retirement
um because currently my husband is the
only one working and he does have a um
I believe he has a 401k in the Roth I
believe it's called
do you guys have any money set aside for
savings that's kind of liquid that you
can get to
yes we do how much
um I want to say we have about 13 000
right now okay so you got a good solid
emergency fund and then it's time to do
some real investing crypto is
um gambling
right and I think you know I'm gonna I
don't know do you know that the that the
you know the last year and a half have
been really unkind to crypto
yes I remember watching it during covid
but right after we invested and I
remember watching it go really low and
then going back up high and now we're
just sitting there
but I mean you've noticed the news that
one of the larger scams in history was
perpetrated in crypto
yes yes sir makes makes Bernie Madoff
look like small potatoes okay so the the
scams are all everywhere around it the
it's an ins it's an unstable place to
put money agreed
yes sir okay all right so I don't put
places I don't put money in places that
are unstable
someday crypto May stabilize and someday
it may have a track record but until it
does I won't be putting any money in it
and I was saying that back when I had
got entire pages of Reddit devoted to
hating me and entire pages of uh Tic Tac
hating me
and everything because I'm telling
people not to put money in stupid but
crypto Come On Dave so um but you know
and now I'm now I'm a genius you know
but I also told them not to invest their
money in Beanie Babies a few years ago
and people were believing in that too so
it's almost like you've lived to see a
few things it's almost like years it's
almost like yeah that's how I lost my
hair but yeah so
uh Joe's in Brooklyn New York hi Joe
welcome to Ramsey Show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call a
long time listener and first time caller
thanks how can we help
yeah so I'm in a bit of a predicament
um and it involves uh basically a money
that I owe to family and friends as well
as an upside down car but I think uh
what kind of led to this situation kind
of goes back a few years maybe four to
five years when I became heavily
involved with Forex Trading or currency
trading
um and eventually got me to a point
where I was losing a ton of money
started taking out credit cards and
funding
um kind of that endeavor that way and
then eventually when I ran out of money
out of my credit cards I would start
taking out personal loans once I
couldn't take out any more unsecured
loans I started taking loans against my
car and then eventually ended up
borrowing from friends and family and so
you sound like this sounds like an
addiction yeah it was an addiction
um and so unfortunately it got to a
breaking point to where I had to file
for bankruptcy uh may as of last year
um but I did keep
um my secured loans as well as the money
I borrowed from my family and like I
went through therapy and all all that so
it was really a truly truly a traumatic
time for me and so I'm sorry now yeah
and like now I'm at a point where I just
really want to I have been actively
trying to tackle this
um the so what do you owe on the car
yeah so there are two cars involved
um my personal car I owe 13 600 at a
rate of 24 mm-hmm
and during the time
um I actually took a loan out
um and I used my brother's car as
collateral for 4 700 which is the
remaining balance as of today okay and
what is the 13 600 car worth
that's worth right around say like forty
three hundred dollars okay and what do
you make
uh my net income per month is 65.50 okay
and you live in Brooklyn New York
yeah
ouch
okay because you got an expensive place
to live right
no no luckily
um my one of my brothers and I we found
a pretty uh inexpensive place to live so
my rent right now is right around 1100
which includes utilities and that's my
share what do you do for a living
uh I am in business development and
sales for a tech startup here in Midtown
Manhattan okay
if you work more there does your income
change
um as of right now I'm like tapped out
with like the number of hours I'm
putting in I'm like working from like 7
30 in the morning on up until like 7 30
in the evening like Monday through
Friday all right well here's what I
would do if I woke up in your shoes
all right yeah are these your only two
debts no you have the family debt yeah I
have my family debt
um totaling ninety thousand dollars okay
and I'm sorry
okay
um well your brother's car concerns me
more than yours
because you need you need the you need
the stress of not screwing up his life
off of your back
yeah that would bother me more than my
own personal car does it you
and they're almost the same amount no no
yeah and it's a smaller amount I'm sorry
it's 14. so that's easy anyway so what I
would do is you know start doing a
really really tight budget and just
attack his debt like a Vengeance knock
it out then attack your car debt and
just knock it out there's not another
answer for it you just got to live on
absolutely nothing and really in about
four or five months you ought to go
knock both of these out
if you just live on nothing you don't do
anything anyway but work so you don't
need to go out and party or go out to
restaurants you don't need money
you got to put it all on this and so hey
we're going to help you with part of
your healing we're going to put you
through Financial Peace University hold
on I'll have them have Austin pick up
and get you signed up for that
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America it's
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones here at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
Elizabeth is with us in Minneapolis hey
Elizabeth what's up
hi
um I just have a quick question maybe a
life debate here honestly
um I'm 26 years old
um I am a 911 dispatcher
um and I'm trying to pay off my debts I
have maybe a total of 600 in medical
bills and then I have a car payment I
got a new card due to some other issues
back in 2021
I've been making payments even extra
payments when I can
um
I have roughly 19 3 left on my car
I recently switched 911 centers because
I wanted to work with law enforcement
and I finally had the opportunity to do
so
um but my old Center that I still have
connections with and I could go back to
um is kind of tugging on me in a way
because at my new center I don't have
room for overtime there's not a lot of
overtime because it's a smaller center
compared to the center that I was at
before
um so you were doing 9-1-1 before
correct I've been a 911 dispatcher for
five five years now why did you change
from one Center to the other Center
I felt burnt out I felt that maybe EMS
EMF for me um and I'm now experiencing
unfortunately as bad as I wanted to do
law enforcement I wanted to do law
enforcement dispatchment I started you
were doing 9-1-1 before you're doing
9-1-1 now how did you think that was
going to solve burnout I don't
understand
calls compared to now just dealing with
passing both said calls along
um there's not as much overtime so I
wouldn't be tempted to work as much at
my old Center I would pull like 14 to 16
days in a row without a break
um but roughly like anywhere six to from
six to eight hours in between shifts so
what was the pay cut with you switching
centers how's that affected your income
the peacock actually wasn't
um I actually got a 40 Cent increase
um switching centers
um but I have para which is the
Minnesota law enforcement
retirement
um that they automatically take out
because when you first get hired it'd be
very useful
not not your hourly rate your income is
way down because you're not working
nearly as many hours right
correct so what did you make a year
before and what do you make a year now
um before it was I have it written down
to me I apologize to me one second here
's the thing if you're not going to work
the extra hours at the call center
because it's too much on you mentally or
it's too much on your mental health fine
but you gotta find a way to fill that
Gap because you've got this debt that
you've got to pay off right so if
whatever overtime hours that you were
working whether it was 15 or 10 or
whatever it was per week you've got to
put that same effort into another job
that's making you just as much money I
don't want you to take a pay cut because
you got to get out of this debt
and I'm not saying it has to be at the
911 Center
okay what are you making and that was
like my
what do I make 31.81 an hour okay and
your income and what did you and so you
made 31.40 before
correct okay and um but you're working
half as many hours
80 hours every two weeks but I don't
have that extra like 20 to 30 hours that
I would put on myself at my old center
right so we got to find that elsewhere
right so I guess my question was it or
is I have an opportunity to go back to
my old Center and get that overtime and
help pay off debts or
I would pick up like I don't know what
other type of job other than like maybe
instacart or something just because of
how crazy disparate spinner hours are
yeah look you that wouldn't be as much
you've already told us that when you
were doing 80 plus hours at the old
Center it wasn't sustainable and that's
fine like I understand I mean I've never
done it but when you tell me that it's
stressful to your mind I believe you
and that's fine if you don't want to
work more than 80 hours at that
particular 911 call center at your old
one the point is you've got to get those
hours somewhere whether that's instacart
that's driving Uber I would love for you
to be able to make the same amount per
hour that you were making
but you got to get this debt paid off
what else have you done as a side hustle
that you could do
um I've never honestly had a side hustle
before
um once I became a dispatcher that kind
of just basically it
um I used to work in like food industry
like my very first job before anything
else was like Chick-fil-A
um
all right so yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
look around for something I can do
whether it's dog sitting Uber uh
instacart I don't care uh what it is but
I'm gonna look for something I can do
that you can make really good money at
for a short period of time that you can
work around your normal 40 hour schedule
and I'm gonna stay where you are
okay because your need for extra hours
is only nineteen thousand dollars worth
then you don't have a need then you
don't have a need for extra hours you
make fifty thousand dollars a year
you can live on fifty thousand dollars a
year in Minneapolis
if you don't have a nineteen thousand
dollar car payment right
right okay and so what I want you to do
is just temporarily for like one year
Gear Up work your butt off and keep the
job that you like because what you're
saying is I was gonna hold my nose and
go back to the other place in order to
get out of debt instead I would just
stay where you are hold my nose and work
an extra gig of some kind find a good
hustle and grind side Hustle
and knock yourself out for a year and be
debt free and then quit the side hustle
and have a great life
yeah you're gonna be free before you
know it I think in your mind you're
trying to change your whole world you
don't need to change your whole world
you just need to get a side job work it
and pay off twenty thousand dollars of
debt and you'll never go back to the old
job that was burning you out and you're
working freaking 80 hours I'd sell a
stupid car
before I did that but I think you can
just pay off the car in a year and keep
it by working a side hustle it's what I
would do and then
um then you've got your best world you
got you set your best world up that's a
good move Justin's with us Justin's in
Atlanta hi Justin welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey Dave my wife and I have been
listening to you for around five years
so thanks for all the wisdom thank you
what's up
quickly is what's the best way to use
stock grants from our work to pay off
our mortgage early we bought a house
about a year ago we have about 300 000
left on the mortgage we have nearly 16
000 worth of stock grants that of us
quarterly so what would we tell you to
do you've been listening five years
I don't know this specific I there's I
know you don't want me to keep it in
that in that company so I guess the two
options are so I'll just cash it out as
it's vested and throw it at the mortgage
okay so you wouldn't put it in a mutual
fund or an index fund and let it grow a
little bit
nope you're already investing fifteen
percent you've been listening five years
what's baby step six pay off the
mortgage
it's not invest extra in mutual funds
no it would be to put it into a mutual
fund until it got to be the amount for
the write-off for the mortgage have you
ever heard me say that in five years
no but I've never heard this specific
question but you've heard people say why
don't I put it into a mutual fund
because they call every week and say
that why don't I just put it into a
mutual fund instead of paying off my
money that's what you want to do that's
what you wanted to do from the moment
you called I genuinely don't want to do
either or no okay well then let's get
another word I just let's say
depending on the timeline that you have
um unusual that's if you're saving up
for something in this case go ahead and
continue to invest your 15 into your
mutual funds into your retirement and
then we Chuck anything extra to the
mortgage and in this case you selling
those vested stocks or getting out of
those stocks is going to be something
that you can check toward the mortgage
don't put it in a mutual fund it's a
baby step six move that's exactly what
it is that's your baby step six Flex
there you go dude this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
1 5 let the wise hear an increase in
learning and the one who understands
obtain guidance
BB King said the beautiful thing about
learning is that nobody nobody can take
it away from you oh
it's good stuff Jade warshaw Ramsay
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America Andrew is
next he's in Charlotte North Carolina hi
Andrew welcome to the Ramsay show
hey how's it going better than we
deserve what's up
um I am calling because uh me and my
wife we are both 20 years old and uh
we we've been doing the Ramsey plan and
we paid all our debt and everything and
uh now we are thinking of uh kind of
changing our jobs because now we aren't
really wanting to do something just to
collect a paycheck we want to uh do
something we enjoy more and something
that's more impactful um than just
trying to weigh the options on that
because it is going to be a pay cut uh
with that so very cool what are you
thinking about getting into
um I want to go into uh
youth ministry at my local church and um
she wants to uh she currently the
preschool teacher kind of like a private
kind of thing that wants to go into the
public school setting um just as an
assistant okay what's it going to take
for you guys to make those transitions
um I guess just uh just applying and
hoping we get it
um
so what's your household income now and
what would it be if you did this
um right now it's about 100K
um and it'd be moving to between UH 60
and 65. okay all right well what I would
want to do is a path
that takes me somewhere rather than just
down
and so
um neither one of these things sound
like what you will be doing when you're
45.
the number of 45 year old youth pastors
is fairly small
okay so you likely would move I mean a
normal path would be to move towards uh
associate Master maybe senior pastor
later that's a fairly normal path I mean
I've got a friend who's 67 he's a senior
pastor of a major mega church and a
metropolitan area started as a youth
pastor decades and decades ago okay so I
want to path a career path that
[Music]
um
increases my Effectiveness increases my
joy increases the scale of the people
I'm helping and if these moves take me
on that path
good if they're a step in that direction
but just I'm going to dumb down my life
to have more joy when I'm 20 no right
okay I think both of these things are
congruent with what I'm talking about
though
in other words I think your wife could
move into this public setting with the
idea of become you know getting her
degree becoming getting her
certification becoming a teacher maybe
even someday uh doing some uh tutoring
maybe even opening up her own tutoring
operation and at 50 years old owns uh 17
of those across 14 States I don't know
I'm making that up okay but it can start
with being the assistant teacher right
right
and it's all teaching
and you can start with being the youth
pastor of a small congregation that
doesn't pay squat
and be serving the lord but that doesn't
need to be your end game agreed
I agree yeah so let's lay out a better
end game and then move in these
directions because otherwise you're
running from something instead of two
something
okay
so jump online with Ken Coleman and let
me do this I'm going to give boat I'm
going to give you two of the assessments
the career assessments that Ken
developed and our research team
developed and I want you to take those
and they're going to give you some
indications on what you can do where you
can go and then I want you to lay out
and say all right how does this end
there's an old book that's fabulous
called The Seven Habits of Highly
Effective People by Dr Stephen Covey and
one of the Seven Habits of Highly
Effective People effective in Ministry
effective in the classroom effective in
business effective people as they begin
with the end in mind
and the end being okay like when you're
my age dude I'm 63. what are you going
to be doing I'm glad I did this with my
life I was a good Steward of my life for
the Lord
all right that makes sense
yes sir yeah
um
now how uh however the only thing um we
did take the uh career assessment we we
uh
we did that this past week oh wow very
good you're ahead of me okay
cool yeah yeah
so did it solidify what Dave is telling
you
uh yes yes and I mean it seems more like
uh that's the direction we should be
going but I think we just need to like
you're saying just have more
um a more like long game plan yeah
that's right so I mean when when we
started this business uh the year we
started it I made 120 000 the year
before doing real estate and this is
1994. okay and we opened we opened shop
in 1994 moved out of my living room into
a little a little tiny office and that
year I made 60.
so pretty much what you're talking about
I went from 100 and 100 and some change
down to 60 and Sharon's like where's the
financial piece
after that that was not oh we're going
to be satisfied and that's what God's
calling us to do and we're going to have
the joy of helping people and we're
going to make half the money no we knew
that we could help more people and more
people in their fi and over the years
we've found lots of ways to help people
and lots of ways to expand what we do
here and the effectiveness of it and
it's been not only very satisfying but
very lucrative yeah
good you have you have to have a
long-term vision Tiffany is in Memphis
Tiffany we're short on time go straight
to your question
yes so we are in Memphis as you said and
we're looking to make a move to
Chattanooga
um next year possibly around May and
we're wanting to have a really big down
payment
um so we would use the profits from our
home but any extra money should we put
that on top of our mortgage payments as
like a savings or put it in like a
high-yield savings account separately
doesn't matter
okay I just wasn't sure if there was
like a tax like you're paying less tax I
don't there's no tax on your sale of
your home you're going to have no tax on
and uh up to half a million up to a half
a million dollars married filing jointly
and uh the that's profit that has
nothing to do with the mortgage
okay and I meant interest rate I just
wasn't sure if we put more towards it I
guess
it didn't matter because you're paying
interest rate anyways yeah yeah you're
gonna make about the same interest
you're gonna you're gonna pay taxes on
the interest on the high yield but it's
not enough money the big difference here
is that you say the the money that you
have one year from now will not be due
to this decision it will be due to how
much money you put into it
but you're not gonna make any money on
it either way both of them are two or
three four percent
since four grand so if you have a
hundred thousand in there it's because
you put a hundred thousand in there not
because of the four grand
okay perfect see what I'm doing okay yep
if you're doing if you're doing it for
10 years the interest rate matters a lot
sure if you're doing it for one year it
doesn't matter much I mean it's a
glorified shoe box to put money into
I like it I like the plan so just think
it through I like paying extra on the
mortgage because it doesn't accidentally
end up in a bass boat that's what I
would do
that's what we did that's what you did
when we got ready to move you're ready
that was your go plan we continued we
were making extra payments on the
mortgage before and we knew we were
moving and we thought let's just keep
doing that because we know it's not
going to get spent on anything else yep
that way it gets stuck it's a forced
savings plan that's right you can't get
your money out except by selling or
refinancing so you don't accidentally go
buy a new car yeah you know oops you
know people do this sometimes I've heard
that uh yeah exactly randomly happens
they were forced into it they were
forced into it and now they're in
repossession yeah
ouch scary out there it's really really
scary it's a good question Tiffany and
it's you know here's the beautiful thing
about what you're asking you're one year
away and you're actually thinking about
it this is what adults do well done
Tiffany adults devise a plan and follow
it children do what feels good and are
impulsive and YOLO their butts off so
it's more fun to be an adult by the way
you have more choices children don't
have choices they get told what to do by
the adults that puts the shower of the
Ramsey Show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]